from the home instructors but this
process was really hard to scale up
due to the you know just the need for
us to be split across research and
teaching and all the things that we have
to do
and so more recently we've partnered the
alburn has established a partnership
with pine biotech and they've developed
a library of courses
that much like the lecture series the
students can take at their own pace
and this is going to address parts of
the critical need for education in this
field
and initially we we established this in
summer of 2018
and we got 25 educational licenses that
we purchased through the lbrn for use
by the lbr and pui campuses and then
additional licenses
were supported through the cct and all
of our attendees worked through hands-on
educational material that was provided
at pine biotech through their edu t bio
info uh course portal and this was
genomics metagenomics and several
transcriptomics courses
and all of our students were then
encouraged to present project posters at
the elder and annual meeting which many
of them did
and because of the pilot's success it's
been since expanded into a partnership
and and i'm going to hand things over
right now to
elliot because he really is
going to be better to give you an
overview of the edu both the educational
offerings that find biotech has through
this partnership
in addition to some of the uh
bioinformatics pipelines that they can
support
thank you
so i wanted to thank you chris for the
introduction
and i wanted to kind of take the time
to briefly introduce a few resources
that our team has developed to support
training and research in bioinformatics
as well as now data science for both
students and faculty to leverage
in their biomedical research or learn
about the publicly available data sets
and become proficient in analytical
methods to process
analyze and interpret these effectively
so the omics logic resources are
designed around
kiomics data types as chris mentioned
with big data cloud-based data analysis
tools
coding exercises and r and python as
well as
project-based tutorials that combine
biological or biomedical topics with
data analytics
statistical analysis principles and
curated data sets
in a variety of applications and so what
our company really does is provides an
opportunity for recent graduates
and students to leverage their skills in
bioinformatics and computational biology
to train and mentor others with a
growing community of over 7 000 students
worldwide
and now a growing community in louisiana
which we're very excited about
and so the academic oversight for work
is ensured by a close collaboration with
the tower bioinformatics research center
which is at university of haifa
in israel and is directed by dr alfred
album dr lina brodsky
so the center recently signed a
memorandum of understanding with
louisiana state university
to collaborate on research projects
expand these training programs and
establish
faculty and student exchange programs so
hopefully
this will be possible after the pandemic
but also due to the increased online
opportunities that have been highlighted
due to these unfortunate events as we
can see here in this virtual conference
hopefully virtual use of these resources
will be enhanced
so let me introduce the specific
solutions that we have been focused on
for the past several years
recently as was mentioned by chris lbrm
has started offering research licenses
to the tbi info platform
which provides a simple and intuitive
user interface
for processing analysis and machine
learning methods for integration of
multi-onyx data
and to support the growing number of
users we're now offering processing the
data on our shared server infrastructure
as well as on google cloud so now we can
run pipelines on our servers
or you can send them to google cloud
directly and so we're now developing
pipelines that support the analysis of
all mixed data generated by the current
pandemic
such as the virology specific tools for
genomic data
generated by throughout this pandemic
and that includes evolutionary studies
host pathogen interaction
and interest host variation studies
importantly we're now focused
on uh developing user-friendly tools for
annotation and visualization of results
as well
and we hope that this will help link
significant signatures
found in genomic data with biologically
relevant visualization
and reporting capabilities and so we
hope that
these tools will help streamline the
analysis and reporting on important
genomic signatures
that will make the analysis results
clear to both as well as biologists
using these political pipelines we're
also in
final stages of completion for
validation of specific areas
of analysis that combine tools for
cancer research
aging and virology as well as a
collection of tools for
multinomics integration which has been a
topic that has been discussed widely in
scientific literature so these are
available through the lbrn
pipelines sorry licenses that could be
requested from the lbrm
we also realized that many users lack
some basic bioinformatics terminology
and necessary
uh kind of concepts to perform
reproducible analysis so in 2020
we launched a number of data science
training tutorials
combining our six omics specific course
collections
with this new resources developed to
help understand the code
behind many of the algorithms offering
training in statistical analysis
machine learning experimental design
data mining and systems biology
so these include basic as well as more
advanced tutorials with browser-based
r and python exercises where users can
learn about scripting
some popular visualization data analysis
packages for
data science and learn how to apply
those to a variety of different data
types
so and as a result we started developing
a series of data science specific course
collections
that also break down the analytical and
different machine learning methods
into very short tutorials for
asynchronous use
and so we hope to increase using these
resources the capacity
for data mining and machine learning
methods so that those could be used
effectively to analyze
big data sets and do predictive analysis
and together with lbrn we're going to
start offering
these courses as program resources
they will be offered eventually with
lbrn certification
and we're now working with a number of
faculty
throughout the lbrn campuses to help
integrate these asynchronous courses
into curricula offered throughout the
different puis
so to kind of briefly share with you
how we have used these materials over
the past year
and what are some of the ways that the
lbrm community can gain
access to these resources and materials
so as a part of our collaboration with
lbrn
we have this online complete
asynchronous course
that can be accessed by students
throughout the year at any time
starting with an introduction to
bioinformatics and learning about the
logic of data analysis
in application to various omics data
types so this is available
and i think we recently made an
announcement about that
so we will soon announce how people can
actually start that process
these basic materials are offered as an
introduction to bioinformatics module
which can be accessible to life science
students without
any previous experience in
bioinformatics the module covers the
basics of genomics in biomedical
applications
and we recently started the process of
offering this course as an undergraduate
course through the department of
biological sciences at lsu
and it can also be made available for
other campuses that might want to use it
as a gentle introduction to
bioinformatics
the coursework itself was developed
internally primarily but also
other contributors included faculty
such as this course on biomedical data
analysis developed by dr jimanshu rajei
who graduated from lsu and is now a
professor at nicholls state university
in his course he offers an example of
pharmac
pharmacogenomics testing using python
and gives a basic idea of what other
types of various biological data might
require
people to be familiar with
bioinformatics terminology
so based on the course work that was
already presented by chris
we also developed a course on
metagenomics to kind of break it down
into smaller pieces of information that
could be digested more easily
and so these courses offer a variety of
processing tools that we've implemented
into the same
user-friendly interface and that
includes whole genome
mapping onto the database kind to
and data amplicon pipelines
with both a user-friendly and also
the coding aspect of visualization of
that data
so here you can see some of the examples
of the tutorials
including the the famous file seek
package that is often used
we also have now a graduate course that
we offer jointly with the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
at louisiana state university it was led
and organized by dr
gus kasulis dr ramesh subramanian
and the support of dr farhana musara who
is a post-doc
at dr kusulos's lab and as a result of
that experience
we also formed a graduate program on
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
where we use curated data sets from a
number of different epidemic outbreaks
to illustrate analysis methods relevant
for infectious disease monitoring
and biomedical research
using these resources we were able to
offer training to over 200 students in
the past year alone
throughout louisiana and so we collected
anonymous and specific feedback from
students and faculty
to help guide future development of
these resources
we learned that the materials resonated
well with the users and addressed a
pressing need among the student
as well as faculty we also learned that
the platform developed
a unique opportunity for many to use big
data analysis tools for the first time
which otherwise they
would not have an opportunity to use and
many users reported a measurable
increase in their understanding of
technical bioinformatics terminology
and understanding of how to practically
apply such methods
to different types of data sets and
challenges
and we're also excited to see many
undergraduate as well as
graduate students provide feedback for
the asynchronous training materials
the analytical pipelines that they've
used and participation in webinars that
was offered in collaboration with lbrn
and i think that this is especially
relevant because we do have such a
diverse population
of students that have very different
backgrounds and very different levels of
exposure to research
using bioinformatics and data science
and this includes both undergraduate
students and graduate students
throughout the elbow and primarily
undergraduate institutes
institutions as well as faculty that
were able to
learn about different aspects of
bioinformatics and even use
some of those tools in their own
research
so that's all i have for today thank you
for
inviting me to share this
all right uh thanks elia
um if there are any questions for any
either of the either chris or elia now's
a good time
the floor is open for questions if you
have any in there otherwise we'll
transition to dr
lee from there the only comment that we
make remiss is that uh
all new funded projects will go through
review
by both cores and for by our
statistician
before they are awarded uh and there
will be
a session where we're going to be
reviewing
whether the appropriate tools have been
used or what else can be done to
help them move forward as we move
forward
and of course the same issue would be
with new applications coming in
they will be reviewed by both cores and
especially on the statistical side to
make sure that
ahead of the game we have been there uh
i think all of these things will be
available information on the
lbrn website um uh and
we you know i think we will be launching
a lot of these
ultimately would like to create a
curriculum in
pui campuses that use those tools
but we'll move forward with vrn
certification
and hoping to have pui's adopt
certain of this material as chris are
mentioned
in their own curricula as we move
forward so in the interest of time i
think we can proceed thank you